welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down 2011's the thing
now I always found it kind of funny
right that we had a movie that was about
an alien that perfectly mimicked its
victims and then we got a movie that
mimicked that beat for beat even down to
having the exact same title saying this
though I think this is a pretty fun
prequel that ends in a way that makes
you instantly want to put John
Carpenters on throughout this video
we're going to be breaking it down scene
by scene and talking about all the
hidden details and things that you might
have missed in it there's actually a lot
to uncover and deeper layers to it and
hopefully watching this video will help
you enjoy the movie more now there were
several things sequels and remakes
almost put into production over the
years but they all failed to make it
past the screenwriting phase we even
almost got a Sci-Fi series called Return
of the thing that would take place in a
small American town after the events of
the movie we of course had the game
which acted as a sequel and several Dark
Horse Comics that continued the tale
John Carpenter he actually pitched his
own sequel with him setting it after the
events of that first film both Charles
and McCready looking older would be
explain with frostbite and we continue
and see how the thing try to get to
civilization John Carpenter Kurt Russell
and Keith David were all back on board
however making a sequel was more
difficult than making it out of outpost
31 alive things changed though with the
success of the Dawn of the Dead remake
with Mark Abram and Eric newham being
given unrestricted access to Universal's
library of ips stumbling across a thing
they convinced the studio to make a
prequel instead of a sequel or going in
the remake Direction
stating that they wanted to tell the
story of the guys who were just ghosts
in the carpenter classic they thought it
would flesh out the horror of what
happened before it all went down at the
U.S camp we also got several carryovers
from the quote-unquote Dead series with
Mathis van Heineken Jr being involved in
the making of it definitely pronounce
that wrong but his sequel to The Dawn of
the Dead titled Army of the Dead that
was canceled three months before filming
unless he quickly looked around further
projects as we know Army of the Dead it
would continue in another form over at
Netflix with Snyder continuing to direct
the project himself math is though he
was desperate to continue working unless
he kept going back to Universal to try
and get a project realizing a thing
prequel was in development he left at
the chance to direct it due to the
original being his favorite film
alongside a alien obsessing over the
details he learned everything about the
Norwegian camp and also made sure he
developed new ideas that we hadn't heard
or seen before apparently the director
carried a laptop with him at all times
that had thousands of screen captures
from the first film he used this as a
reference point when working with the
set designers and I have to admit but
you can see the love for the original
just in every moment of this film I will
also be calling it The Original I know
the thing is a remake of the thing from
another world but when I say the
original I just mean that apologies now
the directors cited his prequel as a
companion piece to the first film and he
felt blessed to expand upon something he
fell in love with as a teen Without
Really detracting from it wanting it to
be more than a horror that would be a
heavy focus on the human drama with it
missing out on some romantic and sexual
relationships they also lurked at the
source material who goes there which
focus more on scientists rather than the
blue collar workers at the original cast
were seen as I really don't envy the
task that they had ahead of them as the
things got such a big following at this
point but it was always going to be
difficult to top how good that original
was the thing of course famously also
bombed so that was the risk for the
creative team that this wouldn't do well
either because of that I feel like a lot
of the risks they were going to take
eventually got Stamped Out by the studio
which we will talk more about later on
in the video there's a crazy big Reddit
post from someone who worked on the film
that I'll talk about later on but there
were major arguments over the special
effects in the film that caused a lot of
issues in the edit either way it kind of
feels like a cover band playing the
greatest hits of their favorite singers
and knowing Carpenter could have been
involved in an actual sequel it does
feel kind of disappointing Carpenter of
course crafted the first film so he
gained a ton of knowledge about what
went down here and I think having him on
board the franchise again would have
made a massive difference rather than
going with him though the studio went
for this but I actually do think it has
some great aspects in it and that's a
making of and for the next part of the
video Let's actually break down the film
and talk about what went into it
the movie opens with the classic 80s
Universal logo to take us back to the
decade this of course was used to open
the thing up and we also start with an
establishing shot of snow with the same
black font being used the creative team
were actually almost forced into filming
the movie digitally but instead they
decided to shoot on film to make it more
akin to the original this gives it a
slightly grainy effect and keeps the
movie's luck in line with the original
tonally the same score is used as well
whether it's getting shots from a
helicopter just like the original
now the film was actually going to open
up in a completely different way with us
getting a prologue showing the ship's
pilot purposely crash landing on Earth
if you read the expanded lore then you
might have read some instances where the
thing was actually a prisoner in the
cargo hole that was picked up on a
biological Expedition mapping out the
universe however the creature managed to
get out and after the thing assimilated
the pilot it crawled into the snow
before succumbing to the cold and the
ending originally had the pilot in a two
with K coming across it when she entered
the ship model of this was made stuff
was shot and it was placed into the film
but test audiences didn't understand
what this actually was thus they ended
up covering it without weird that weird
Tetris CGI which yeah sorry mate doesn't
look that good it made you look a right
knob now I don't know why they did that
because I doubt anyone was confused over
the engineering alien and I think it
would have added more to the mystery of
what went down on the ship oh my God
what the hell happened here the most
appealing thing about the Norwegian Camp
was wondering what happened and I think
our imaginations could have run wild
with what went down on the ship the ship
itself could have been a prequel to the
prequel without being this film's
version of the Norwegian camp now the
snow cat here started to pick up a
strange SOS Beacon and this was also
used as a sound effect in sunshine
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
actually mimics real frequencies head
from space but no one's quite sure
exactly what they mean some have deemed
them to say hit the like button but the
snow cat cracks through the ice and at
this point they discover the ship
Unfortunately they don't recreate the
shot of the Norwegians standing in the
snow which was picked up from the
footage found at the base kinda sucks
because it's such a famous shot and this
itself also came from a thing from
another world at this point we get a
recreation of the title sequence with
the original being created through
burning a plastic bag that would then
reveal the letters recreated in CGI this
kind of sums up the movie but we do get
some practical carryovers in the next
scene opening on a computer screen we
then cut to a dog-like creature which
was actually a prop from the kennel
scene in the first film yeah we also
catch Kate listening to this
[Music]
now this is actually the song who can it
be now by Men At Work and this song is
probably as close as we're gonna get to
the title who goes there however it's
about paranoia and someone wondering
who's out there which of course plays
into the film's themes Kate was actually
meant to have common character traits
with Alan Ripley from Alien and
interestingly Mary Elizabeth Winstead's
been Fan cast as a daughter several
times before and there was the worry
that putting a male in the lead would
have people making comparisons to Kurt
Russell and with the first film being
nothing but men they thought that a
woman would help dissuade from that
happening now she's not the only one
who's meant to act as a tribute to
what's come before and at this point we
then meet Sanders Sanders is supposed to
be based on Arthur Harrington from the
thing from another world with them even
rocking similar hats later on in the
film he was constantly talking about
signs and how that would save them and
as far as attitudes go he acts extremely
similar asanes was originally played by
Dennis storhole and they shot a week's
worth of film with the actor in the role
however he was a apparently fired you to
his alcoholism though it has to be said
he staunchly denied this was the case
several of the scenes shot with them
though such as the arrival at duel
actually have moments with him in it but
they digitally replaced his face okay
it's seen as the perfect paleontologist
and I like the shorthand here of having
her studying a frozen creature which
does explain why they picked her for the
Dig she's of course American as well and
Universal yeah it weren't exactly gonna
put out a film with nothing but
Norwegian speakers in it we actually get
several other Americans in a Brit as
well and she's joined by the likes of
Adam and Joel edgerton's Carter he says
that he can't get hold of a newspaper
that isn't three weeks old and he wants
to know how his team the Cavaliers are
doing originally this line was gonna
have a bit about him being unable to
reach the American camp on the radio
which would of course hint to McCready
and his group there's also a deleted
scene where they contact Outpost 31 but
as I'm sure you can guess they are
unable to reach them calling Outpost 31
urgent to come in over
try a lot of frequency I can't reach the
next room on this bloody thing did you
reach anybody yet
reach anybody we're a thousand miles
from nowhere man and it's gonna get a
hell of a lot worse before it gets any
better well stick to it window stick to
it flying out of the camp we see a
perfect Recreation of the Norwegian one
a Hut like mccready's and the yellow
snow truck that appeared in the original
we can also catch a sign which says
through station though I have been told
it's pronounced too which itself has its
own meaning tool is said to be the most
northern region of the world and in
ancient Greece a myth centered around
and Explorer traveling to it said to be
the farthest of all lands that existed
where the knights were only three hours
long and the Summers lasted an age
that's like the opposite of this
location and instead the remoteness
leaves them in isolation now the taken
to the crash site and as they enter we
see a strangely shaped ice formation
sitting to the left this was meant to be
another xenomorph with the same effects
team here working on Alien 3 and Alien
vs Predator we meet the rest of the team
who then unveil the ship looking
identical to how it did originally they
discussed the signal which I think was
more likely a warning rather than the
SOS that they think it is going outside
we see the ice containing the thing
which is later brought out like a block
identical to the original I always felt
like this was meant to Echo a coffin and
back at the base we meet wait is that is
that my man from Game of Thrones it's
him it's bloody him I want to make
babies with her at this point sander
says make sure that everyone stays off
the radio which again was supposed to
cement why Windows hadn't spoken to them
what about him is he completely
disinterested oh that's Lars he doesn't
understand English hello is out of all
these people he's the only person who
makes it to that first film but as we
know he's killed during the opening he
of course couldn't speak English
explaining why he just didn't do that
like the rest of the guys are doing he's
with his dog too and as they ride the
Block in we can see that he's by his
side kinda sucks knowing what happens
and retroactively it makes our opening
scene even more personal drilling into
the ice to get a tissue sample they
accidentally push too far and this digs
into the creature which ends up waking
it up now not to be like leave the thing
alone the poor little thing but I think
that had they not done this the entire
Expedition it would have been absolutely
fine for this video I actually tried to
sympathize with the thing and think
about how it operates and to me it's a
creature that rarely goes on the attack
I think it normally acts in self-defense
and it's mostly upon being harmed that
it decides to counter during the
original it was happy just hiding out
lying low until things like the blood
test caused it to reveal itself that hot
needle was what set things off and it
was only then that it actually came
forth now there's always at the moment
with Nares and many of the arise that
using the paddles is what sets the thing
off as it sees it as an attack due to
them creating an electric shock now I
know that it of course goes out hunting
for creatures to assimilate but I think
that in this drill acts like an attack
on it and that's what sets it off now
when building these sets they also
didn't know how tall to make everything
so what they did is they actually used
Kurt Russell's height and how tall he
looked in the scenes to create all the
measurements throughout these scenes we
also see the dark trying to escape the
kennel echoing the moment from that
first film after Derek watches it wait
is that Matt is that Mr Echo bloody it's
Mr Echo yes now after Derek watches it
Escape he runs toward everyone and
catches them in the middle of a song not
gonna try to pronounce the name but it's
about a kid walking in the woods and
coming across a cuckoo
now Cuckoos are actually known as brood
parasites because they lay their eggs in
the nests of other birds these birds and
raise the chicks thinking that their own
which may rip upon how the thing
integrates into other groups either way
that night it ends up bursting through
the ice and they do a great bit of
attention to detail which carries over
from the thing like the thing thing the
the A2 version technically it's not a
carryover that's happening setting it up
now in that scene just before doc enters
the room we can see above McCready that
the roof's been destroyed this is why
there's icicles coming down from it snow
lettering ground and the roof being
destroyed like this explains why the
room's the way it is they then go
searching for it and the current form of
the thing aggressively attacks the
workers it comes across and completely
tears them apart when discussing the
film The Creative team said this was
intentional and it was upon assimilating
a human that it started to think and act
like us rather than being like a wild
beast from this point it's far more
calculated and strategic so in paranoia
because it knows that's our weaknesses
it's an idea I really like and though I
might have crapped on the movie at the
start I do think it has these really
nice touches that do show they cared
about it this is also the only point
which Greeks could get taken as just
before it breaks free we see him going
outside of the helicopter when they
venture out Sam even asks him about the
chopper and he says great
leave that open I don't remember this is
kind of a clue as if he was a human he
would have likely closed the door
naturally as a force of habit keeping
things closed while these characters
would be used to doing so him not doing
it shows that something was amiss
elsewhere another team comes across
blood of the kennel explaining how lost
his dog would come to be infected now
the two unlucky red shirts see the
creature underneath the Hut and it's
only upon burning it that it completely
wipes it out bullets fail to work
because each cell acts individually
unless it has to be incinerated at a
molecular level with the body on the
table they start to examine it and this
Echoes the scene from that first film
discovering Henrik was being mimicked
Juliet runs out the room and it's at
this point that she's comforted by
Griggs later on Kate discovers blood in
the shower and I think this belongs to
her and it's when he attacked as we see
Juliet runs down the hall and then Greg
stares at ale likely planning his next
move now it's his blood in discovering
the fillings that makes Kate realize
someone's been taken over and she rushes
outside to try and get the helicopter to
land it's at this point that Griggs
makes his move but personally I always
thought this this was a bit stupid the
thing to me yeah it only reveals itself
when it has to and and it'll even attack
other things to keep its cover up this
just seems like a dumb move because it
could have just landed and this crash
kills it when it's ammo is to survive
Kate then goes forward to talk about the
blood in the shower and we see as the
group they start to get a little bit
paranoid now it's mother Julia and
Edward who suggests I should leave and
look for the others and as we learn both
of these are the thing in the case of
Edward though we can't reduce when this
happened as there's not really a scene
like there was with Griggs and Juliet
however I think due to them both trying
to separate the group that it happened
before this scene and they both played
the team and made them split up upon K
presenting the fillings he also shuts
down the conversation because he knows
this is a way to determine who is who
what are those I think they're fillings
from someone we wasted too much time
already lost listen
now from this point most of the people
leave the room and Juliet throws
suspicions on Colin to try and guard
Kate into following her she's just like
come with me we need to talk about this
in secret over in this private room that
no one else is in yet don't go there
love you're an idiot but yeah at this
point she of course goes to make her
move and the creature comes forth and
then starts to attack her now a debate
that's constantly had in the thin
Community is whether those infected
actually know they are Palmer
highlighting Norris's heads made many
suspect that they don't and it's
possible that this scene also backs it
up now when they open the door to see
her assimilating Carl Juliet's looking
at them almost like she can't control
what's happening it's only when Kate
says burn it that the thing side of the
body notices them even though Juliet's
been looking at them the whole time
therefore it could indicate that
Juliet's a separate entity and the
reason she doesn't react is because
she's still in there somewhere huge it
adds to Outpost 31 on Reddit for
pointing that out and I actually think
that it makes a lot of sense now outside
we get a scene that riffs on the burning
one from the first film in which they
stand about as the fire of the things
corpse provides the light in the night
this is where McCready discussed how
easily it can hide and we even get some
lines that play off that movie any of us
this thing doesn't want to show itself
it wants to hide inside an imitation
he'll fight if it has to
but it's vulnerable out in the open
to be alone
vulnerable
that's exactly what it wants laws ends
up showing Kate a box of grenades which
we know he'd like to use when trying to
hunt the dog at this point they're
interrupted by Edward who possibly
wanted to make a move thinking he may be
alone now Sam and Derek then stumbled in
having made it out of the crash and then
across the Wilderness everyone's
suspicious but there's actually some
kind of tribalism here as Kate doesn't
want them dead due to the pair being
American we see this later on with the
Norwegians ours is sticking together and
Sanders trying to play up the distrust
with the Americans I think honestly you
probably would trust people from where
you're from more and it touches upon the
sides and biases we have which is a
really clever thing to talk about them
coming in from the snow of course is
like when McCready returned from the
heart and Sam also says some lines that
are similar to Docs
start working on a new test I need Doc's
help yeah you don't want to drug me
Mac I'm not a prisoner preparing a blood
test I thought we were going to get a
remake of that scene but the thing Burns
it up and we watched the lab set on fire
Edward's the only one who is a thing at
this point and you can kind of seem
strategically watching the others start
to suspect the rest he actually breaks
up the fight between Colin and Adam
which would win him some points as being
a more level-headed group member now
from here we go to the filling scene
with K examining the teeth of every
single person as soon as the British guy
was like I've got no feelings I was like
he's the [__] thing he has to be the
thing there's no way a British guy
doesn't have any feelings now I don't
actually have any feelings but let's be
honest British dentistry in the 80s
wasn't wasn't the best interestingly
Colin's the only person from the no
filling gang who doesn't become a thing
and he's the one that Juliet threw
suspicion on before now another clue
that Edwards actually the creature is
that he's the only group member who
doesn't open his mouth he just
completely skips through the test
because I think he's trying to show he's
willingly going along with things I
think my big problem with the scene is
that you think it's going to go
somewhere but ultimately it doesn't and
we're just left with a dull feeling it's
a complete opposite to the original
which had that tension building up and
then you hit a point where you thought
nothing was gonna happen the bang Palm
is revealed as a thing catching you
completely off guard after this
extremely intense moment the channel
horror culture went into the issue with
this and also played this interesting
clip directly from the commentary as a
fan you'd think a case it's it's blood
testing and somebody will pop up pop
open
um but actually we don't which is
actually better now I disagree with this
and I think it's better to actually have
the tension capitalize on that but let
me know below exactly what you think
outside larsenko go out looking at a
heart which resembles a scene in which
McCready and the Gang go out to Blairs
the back inside engine starts to mount
with Sanders pointing out the American
thing and Edward backing him up
about it
again it's a masterful play to so
distrust and when Sam and Derek break in
Allah McCready Edward's the one who eggs
Peter on to not trust them and to burn
them just like Clark and the thing Peter
is shot and killed and the revealing
both is that the character was actually
human Edward is wounded during the
explosion of his flamethrower which is a
kintenors getting hurt when McCready
breaks back into the base in the case of
that Norris find a hard issue whereas
Edward here he just acts unconscious he
launches his arms as he carried in and
we see as his body starts to morph while
Carter tries to burn him this kindly
builds off the back of McCready being
unable to ignite the flamethrower during
the blood test and it allows Edvard to
make contact with Adam now this is one
of those moments that always comes up
first when I think about this film my
kids right sometimes gonna might sound a
bit weird but they'll crawl on me yeah
that they're 18 months old but they'll
crawl on me like headbutt me and just
push their faces into mine right and I
always think about this whenever that
happens just they're trying to absorb me
the kids are trying to kill me another
thing get another thing
I think this shows just how quick it can
contaminate and it's the one time we see
how assimilation actually works just
connecting to Adam's skin allows it to
start to absorb him and making contact
with his saliva is how it starts to
spread now the 82 version has been seen
as a metaphor for HIV which itself is
spread through bodily fluids maybe it
was building off that and later on Kate
says she's gonna try and reach the
Russian camp this might be a comment on
the Red Scare and that was a theme that
popped up in the thing from another
world now all this stuff leans heavily
into the CGI side of stuff but as we
talked about there was a lot of back and
forth with the VFX the effects team did
a lot of the work practically with them
building animatronic creatures and
puppets for the thing now according to
Reddit user mice and dram they had
access to the film and know what went on
they wrote a big post detailing a lot of
the behind the scenes stuff and what in
the end this studio ended up changing
they said that the people making the
movie weren't doing it for a paycheck
and they had a ton of awesome things
that never made it to the film a created
all these scenes using practical puppets
that would then be enhanced slightly by
CGI elements however the studio said it
looked 280s and ordered everything to be
replaced completely with CGI I think
it's a shame as the 82 films of course
now for its effect and the work robotine
did is legendary inside we can also
catch Jonas up against the wall which
reminded me a bit of Windows after Palma
bit him Kate Burns him and his legs go
back and forth just like Windows did
when McCready pulled the trigger now Sam
gets an ax and they walk through the
corridors looking for the other arm that
escaped out of Edvard planning it in the
wall you can catch this ax in the
original and see him better there as the
group start to walk about the bass
[Music]
yeah leave it mate just leave it there
there's no need to take a weapon with
you and it needs to be that when
McCready shows up so just leave it and
this is grabbed and we also have Colin
who becomes the guy in the chair that
took his own life there was actually a
deleted scene that showed him locking
himself in a room and then he discovered
the thing was in there with him but
nowhere to go he then grabs the racer
and slumps down in the chair that he's
later found in now this was removed for
pacing issues but I kind of like how it
plays out and ties into the original
either way we still see his fate at the
end and at least we kept the focus on
the Edvard Adam thing burned and running
outside this obviously becomes a
two-headed one that McCready and Co
bring back from the camp realizing that
Sanders is heading to the ship they then
decide to mount up to stop it taking off
and during this we of course have Carter
working with Kate and them taking the
grenades at Lars showed them earlier in
the snow cat we get a quick shot where
we focus on his earring which is
important to bear in mind for the final
few moments as they run along the ship
we see the blue light powering it up and
this is similar the strips that we could
catch at the beginning of the original
caught inside the ship Kate has to take
the creature on which he kills with an
explosive like how the blare thing was
taken out I think they need to put
Santa's face in the creature really
ruins the effect here and from what I
can gather this wasn't always going to
be the case originally it was actually
just going to change into the pilot and
then Carter would arrive and help take
it down this would be a way that it
could buy Kate's trust and make her
think that he was one of the good guys
now when I was on his face eventually
turns more like what we'd expect but
yeah I just think a kind of Scorpion
Kings is a bit when it really didn't
need to also the thing puts tentacles
around a gap to try and grab her but it
could just like I don't know detach and
send other things away but it doesn't
just wait for a shape shifter to get
stuck on something but allows her to
grab the grenade and finally take it out
it's the old explosive in the mouth
trick which Mary Elizabeth would also do
in 10 Cloverfield Lane powering down the
ship both she and Sam make it out but
there's just one thing going on that
might cause an issue the pair was
separated and therefore Kate doesn't
know if he can be trusted and we did get
a shot when he heard something down the
corridor when he was on the ship now
when they're in the snow his earrings
missing and she Burns him because when
questioned he reaches for the wrong ear
because of this it makes Kate think that
he's the thing and she refuses to take
the chance that he might be the creature
now during the burning scene they play
the thing screams over the top but many
have felt this doesn't necessarily
confirm he's the alien there's also the
argument that the thing takes someone's
memories and this is how it's able to
copy languages and so on instead of
doing blood tests you could just be like
who did you say your favorite
breakdowner was again and as soon as
they say Ryan area you know that you
know they're a liar and a piece of [__]
and a [__] judge a character so some not
doing the earring thing it doesn't
necessarily confirm it so instead we
should look at the script to see what
the real intention was sorry Ryan if
you're watching this I don't mean it
love you and the script has Sam's face
beginning to elongate immediately just
after she blasts
showcasing their transformation is
underway so that confirms the intention
was to do that but they left the scream
in instead of doing the effect now I
kind of wish they just left it ambiguous
because I think the first film's ending
maintained interest because it doesn't
give us the answers we as the audience
are supposed to be as paranoid as the
characters are second guessing who's the
thing which that ending does perfectly
also the reason that McCready and code
don't see these no cats is because we
can see they enter from the other side
of the ship when they go towards the
hatch we can see it's on the other side
of how McCready saw it and therefore the
helicopter that McCready and Co landed
in wouldn't have seen their snow cats
this is why this stuff didn't get picked
up when the Americans were at the ship
and yeah it's just a nice little bit
that doesn't break the continuity either
way we cut back to the camp and see the
Norwegian helicopter that starts off the
first film while I shoot to a window and
almost hits his buddy in a leg which
Echoes what happens to bennings when he
arrives at the camp now the dog escapes
and Lars demands they take to the sky AI
which segues perfectly into what comes
next we end with footage from the 82
movie with a creature running in the
snow before we cut to Black brilliant
way to close it out and I still get
goosebumps as we end the film now
unfortunately it's unlikely that Kate
survived as it was Carter that knew the
weight of the Soviet base additionally
this screenwriter said they're Bloody
Disgusting that in his script Kate
didn't survive kind of wish right and
sequel ideas here but we could have a
film at the Soviet base where we can
catch Kate coming in and it then kicks
off the Russians could then go to the US
camp and find Charles and McCready and
boom we've got a sequel that pulls them
all together unfortunately though I
doubt it's going to happen as this movie
also flopped and tanked all their plans
earning just 31 million off at 38
million budget at least it copied its
predecessor and also doing badly too
unfortunately whereas Zak gay Nicole
following this doesn't really seem like
it has and yeah I still think there are
good bits in it so it may Mega fans you
should check this out if you haven't but
if you're a mega fan yet you've seen it
already and the director had such a bad
experience that he quit Hollywood and
he's gone on to work solely on Norwegian
films he said the constant Studio
interference made it so he'll never work
with an American Studio again and it
does kind of suck because this was the
guy's favorite film it just seemed like
a dream project I think there is a lot
to like it but unfortunately you know it
just had that impossible task of living
up to what came before they had the
chance to do something that explored the
thing more but instead they stuck to the
same beats and didn't really go anywhere
dugged by the CGI in Practical debate it
seems like no matter who watches this
film that that's always the main
conversation topic that comes up
immediately however I think the floors
also line the way the thing acts and
throughout the movie how it's been
presented a lot of the time it just
attacks for the sake of attacking
whereas in the 82 version it was far
more strategic we also had elements like
the Norris hair the dogs and several
versions that really push the creatives
to the limits when coming up with ideas
the area tends to just be a spiky
creature with tentacles attacking people
and it's not the variety that made the
first movie so memorable think if you're
looking for something to watch then
maybe check it out but I can't imagine
why you'd ever put this on when the
original is there too they're now
playing podcasts actually described it
perfectly and they said it's like warmed
up leftovers of a meal from the night
before sure you enjoyed it that there's
still good things there but it just
doesn't fully recapture what went down
originally still though I hope you
enjoyed the breakdown and if you did
then please hit the Thumbs Up Button
make sure you subscribe for videos like
this every week and if you want to get
access to these videos early then please
click the join button which is 99 cents
a month 99 Pence cheaper than an pound
mix-up I think you can get access to the
Channel all these videos early and yeah
it massively helps us out next time
we're doing The Truman Show I've got a
little thing video in between and then
we're also jumping over to a film I
think you guys are gonna love now if you
missed our this thing break down that's
on screen right now and definitely head
over there right after this by the way
thank you for clicking the video I've
been Paul you've been the thing I love
and I'll see you next time take care
peace